seventy-two party rock let's go
challenge five standard invite here we
go let's see all right let's do it let's
do it here afford is okay King's pond
might we get into really Lopez Spanish
opening Spanish hoping it is if you're
watching first time chess if you don't
know this opening right here is probably
the oldest it's been playing for it's
been played for many years hundreds
right can you say hundreds without
exaggerating yes without exaggeration
hundreds of years okay so
I'm gonna try to get this in let's see
if my opponent could capitalize on it
I'm looking to make use of f1 before I
Castle because maybe I want to keep my
rook on the f1 square
let's go Knight or wait a second wait a
second wait a second now that this pawn
is protected the knight is looking to
maybe pick up my bishop hang on not so
fast
next up Knight g3 I think we've been
here before is this the same player
something with like if the knight plays
here if I take there's recapture if I
grab the night
the knight grabs the pawn with check so
I pretty much want to get to where ok so
there's some time being wasted now that
pond took two steps before it got to d5
that's why I could say that confidently
so a little bit of time has been wasted
on black side I am looking to just
reinforce this point
however if I play ninety three takes
takes Bishop takes pawn Knight here is
not available forget that my rook would
then be guarding a five after the bishop
takes here and I am not afraid of what
what am I not afraid of not afraid of
double to be pawns so let me actually
backup my bishop right now I think that
would be a good idea or would it what
about pawn push actually no no no no no
no no a for the bishops I'm protected
and it allows for pawn takes if I take
the bishop I get hit with the
in-betweener pawn takes Knight hitting
my queen so I'm being cautious about a
pawn move right now if anything Bishop
back to c2 or do I wait to be kicked
away I'll wait to be kicked away I don't
want to play
I was thinking Bishop c2 and then in
response to a4 a3 but that really
weakens the b3 square so I don't have
another choice really capturing right
here is giving up my Bishop Knight takes
open position my opponent would be
beneficial or benefitting okay so maybe
I have thoughts of taking and then
getting this pawn or not so we're
working with this are we yes we are what
about now a3 it's a quiet position nerd
actually it's a pretty tense position
hmm 83 stops this beef four move see if
this if this pawn goes astray like this
I don't want this night to be able to
cause me a headache right here if it
lands on d4 so if I take the knight
recaptures I take the Queen goes here
and then there's a lot of pressure on my
pawn
this becomes awkward for me to deploy my
dark square Bishop so I think in
response to that I'm gonna go with
this I don't want this structure to be
undermined because what's happening is
if I allow this pawn to get to 83 it
means my b2 pond will need to flinch and
if he flinches then you know what that
translates into is black and getting
control over the d4 square so I want to
be very very cautious of the d4 square
right here there is no more pawn advance
and now my opponent is really just
guarding that right thing so what about
what about what can I just move forward
with my plan yeah
what's wrong h4 night night h2 you see
this pond is actually stopping the
knight from getting to this d4 square
because I made the I believe the correct
Queen side pond moves I'm able to run
forward with this h3 Knight h2 an f4
idea but there are still prep moves
needed before I could get that in one
one of those moves being to get my King
off of this diagonal in the meantime
okay we're going to be having pressure
on this and I'm foreseeing maybe an
eventual file opening up and then the
bishop playing here to remove
essentially the glue of my position if I
don't have my bishop around to watch
over d3 I think my whole structure will
crumble let's see I could play Knight g5
I'm gonna do that I want to be able to
rely upon my LightSquared bishop
something tells me that this might be a
bit off though like is the night gonna
be jumping in here real soon I could be
getting the bishop I think so you're
gonna get really weird man this is
really tense I really want to get an F
for soon but I need to get my king out
of the way
I think Bishop III is best and in
response to that I think I should be
just capturing it or maybe not that says
a lot right there capture or maybe not
Bishop III do I let my queen be tethered
to the defense of my bishop that's
usually an uncomfortable situation okay
we're not having that and I don't have
to worry about ninety five okay I have a
lot of it's things have been eased on my
end I think I take this bishop I think
pawn recaptures is good I'm gonna go
here and this is tough the Knights gonna
come to g6 and f4 I went to this square
instead of h2 because I'm planning on f4
and my King could certainly be
accessible along this diagonal I think
I'm kind of forced into it or not am i
forced into it no I'm not going to take
that because I don't want this file to
open up I'm in a position now to do one
of two things take on D and then force
like a bishop recaptures or something if
my opponent really wants to maintain
pressure on D whoa I didn't see that oh
my in trouble am I in trouble no I get
this pun right calculation time one
minute and change take Queen takes King
here no no no takes Queen takes Knight
block that's scary
I don't want to do it No
I don't want to do it no no no no no I
think I should have done it I'm gonna
capture here next I think where's the
Queen gonna go right there let me do
what next
I gotta move quicker and I'm not moving
quicker
let's do this very scary over here dark
squares very very scary but if my
opponent doesn't react properly okay
well I'm gonna take that I can't deal
with this and I think I need to cut off
the circulation here between that Queen
and the night and I think that this is a
good way to do it so 26 seconds left
look at this tension look at how long
this tension was persistent I think both
of us did well to not capture in in all
these different instances where either
one of us could have captured I think
it's best to do how we did and now I
think there's problems or is there no
Knight takes Knight Oh Knight takes
Knight is a good move
Oh looking for a deadly for 33 seconds
to figure it out oh okay I got to do
this I got to get rid of the night and
I'm in trouble this night is so strong
oh is it strong right here I'm dead I
gotta get that night out of there really
quick and I'm not seeing it happen
really quick so blunder right there
towards the end with that capture on
that square we are down on on time here
I'm gonna play here I'm on the night
there's a fork here but there's no time
right we can't really think at this
point I just move pressure on the bishop
in the rook there is no rook there I get
the bishop so that's it no time - no
time what a game very very good game Wow
very nice very very tight I really like
that game very very good let me back up
and let's see
all right I don't know about what like I
thought that this was a good decision
everything right here I wonder about the
Queen move I also wonder at this point
right here I also wonder a bow instead
of the pawn push what about night h5 to
f4 I think there's a possibility for
that so that's one suggestion looking
into that pivot to that Foursquare I
think could be a bit uncomfortable for
me what else maybe this may be a three
maybe this is a reason for me maybe this
is a mistake
castling because it allows for a four a
three and then this pond will be
undermined and you will be able to pivot
about much sooner I mean it didn't
happen in the game but I think black
will be able to make use of the d5
square so a4 instead of the pawn push
here this is something I pretty much
can't stop if I really wanted to stop
that I'm a needing to push forward in
the center or capture but this move this
a3 move I could stop maybe if you get
this in first and I play a pawn move to
be for b3 then when this move is played
I think then black benefits as a result
of those advancing pawn moves I think
that would be a beneficial Queen side
structure for black to get this pawn all
the way down to a three so I think my
first suggestion for white actually for
me in this case is to knock castle but
rather get in a position to just support
efore and meet a four with a three like
I ended up getting in but black did have
one opportunity to play it I played it
now the bishop comes out Age 3 and this
was another thing maybe maybe a once
again trying to get to this f4 square
only this time with what was the Queen
Knight east 7g 6 + f4
be a bit disruptive but at the end of
all this I was not better right here I
miss played it I guess this is good in
blitz right here I think I have a
defense if I capture Queen recaptures
and I block with my knight that way I
don't have to deal with the knight
coming to g4 but this guy is going to be
coming around real soon
getting to f4 or something so this is a
bit awkward good move h5 and this is a
bad move on my part and it was meant
very nicely with Knight takes pawn we
were both in time pressure there but a
really really good game good game out of
the Spanish opening there